the chief executive has got to be bold
within reason and during an application
i recognize very few people watching
this
will become president but i think you
will find lessons in leadership that
will apply to your life
as president sometimes i had information
that the american people didn't know and
therefore had to make decisions what was
best for the country on knowledge that
wasn't evident that's just the nature of
leadership
so long as you're guided by principle
and so long as you're guided by
a cause greater than self you can endure
criticism because it's going to come
one of the things i missed after the
presidency was this daily learning and
thankfully painting came into my life
it's a learning experience because with
every paint stroke you learn something
new all right i'm gonna do another
flower it's important to have a set of
priorities that guide you and your team
your company your managers have got to
understand those priorities to me the
most important priorities was my faith
in my family and my friends that may
sound corny to some but it helps you
reorganize the rest of your life welcome
thanks great glad to be here
when i was speaking to audiences i
didn't want them to think i was smarter
than they were one of the keys to
communication is to figure out how to
enable the person you're talking to to
relax you know i had i was a master at
the malaprop
misunderestimate the press corps
reaction was
the guy really just say that
i remember right after 9 11 in the oval
office talking about praying for
families that had suffered loss i broke
down in tears if your heart is touched
let people know that your heart is
touched
not everybody is going to be a leader
but everybody can end up being a better
person the challenge of life is not to
attain wealth and status and power the
challenge of life is to improve and to
learn to love better and
everybody can do that
i'm george w bush
and this is masterclass
you